it's a tale of endurance and
determination by Rescuers who refuse to
give up
this was once four apartment blocks
unrecognizable now
there were concrete blocks one on top of
each other he tells us up to a hundred
were dead inside but remarkably at least
one teenager called Rima was still alive
we had to go down through this hole and
there was lots of Twisted Metal and
concrete but there was a gap which
formed a tunnel we had to go through
that and another tunnel to get to her
the flats had more or less pancaked the
snatched images on his phone show how
cramped it was as they crawled in one by
one to reach Rina
all the building was resting on this
part any movement and it would all
collapse and we'd lose her
the white helmets volunteers and rima's
relatives were working with very little
no heavy machinery at all at this point
just their bare hands and a lot of
ingenuity
they managed to squeeze their way
through the gaps following the sound of
her screams until they found her cold
and terrified and with her right leg
pinned down by tons of concrete
they covered her with blankets to keep
her warm and using only torches after
hours of crying they realized the only
way to free her and save her life was to
amputate her leg there under the rubble
yeah she can't remember anything of the
amputation and still hasn't been told
her father didn't make it she's just
relieved her ordeals over after 30 hours
of being trapped she realized herself
the only way to get out was to lose her
leg
I told them I told them to cut my legs
she said they tried really hard to save
it but there wasn't any hope and there
was no blood to it at all so they took
the decision to cut it when I was
trapped in the hole there was a dead man
next to me she goes on I was really
afraid I just wanted to get out
[Applause]
she's now hoping to somehow get a
prosthetic still only 14 years old the
night of the earthquakes dramatically
altered her future and so many others
her family lost everything her father
the main Breadwinner as well as their
entire home and all that they had to
their names
at the moment they're staying with Rima
in the hospital so they have some
shelter for now they're just living from
day to day
they're one of tens of thousands who've
lost their homes
this family is digging to find their IDs
and anything they can salvage even
scraps are better than nothing
magdalin is searching for her phone it
has pictures of her ten-year-old on it
all she has left of her son now did were
you talking to him
no there was no voice she says
she and her relatives battle to free him
with no help her son's body was pulled
out two days later
they've survived the earthquake now they
have to live with the aftermath with
little help or aid from outside and much
of it viewed as far too late by those
here
what did the Syrian people do wrong what
is our sin that the world left us like
this are our lives worth nothing why
we're human beings we respect humanity
and respect human rights we're we're not
barbarians
more than a decade of war and a natural
disaster is fast turning into an
humanitarian crisis
in a region perpetually going from
tragedy to tragedy
why were you so late it reads we were
waiting for you
trauma caused by the biggest earthquakes
in a century those who helped the people
here and those who took far too long is
going to be remembered way after the
rubble's been pieced back together again
Alex Crawford Sky News in Aleppo
Province Northwest Syria